go down to Northern California where the
power is still out for some 14 000
customers hit by yesterday's powerful
earthquake and the governor has declared
a state of emergency for that entire
area it's about 200 miles north of San
Francisco pretty part of the state
actually Manuel bojorquez has more on
the Quake now blamed for two deaths and
significant damage
Windows shattered store shelves crumbled
woke me up violently jumped out of bed
and homes were torn apart on front porch
fell off after a 6.4 magnitude
earthquake rocked Humboldt County and if
you look up here that crack entirely
down the wall Haley Smith showed us
where her house cracked usually they
start small so you can get somewhere but
this one started so big that it was hard
to like think it's a big jolt yeah up to
80 aftershocks have been reported whoa
this one hit during a news conference
this part of the state is seismically
active meaning there's a history of
large earthquakes here we can't go back
to the house Jackie McIntosh her husband
and their animals now have to find a new
place to live they were in the process
of selling their home after a previous
Quake scared the family into moving out
of the area part of it was we had a
showing today and someone was going to
put an offer on our house and I'm just
kind of like you know we're alive
they endured a magnitude 6.2 Quake
exactly one year ago and scientists
report this Templar could be a warning
of more to come unfortunately we have no
way of telling whether this is a
foreshock to a larger earthquake we
don't know but this is a great reminder
to be prepared for that next big
earthquake just in case something bigger
were to happen for CBS mornings Manuel
bihorquez Eureka California